on this episode we talk CrossFit and we
talk about is it okay to like your own
picture on Instagram
[Music]
[Music]
this is
Carrie be everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is a 103 of the
askgaryvee show it's a beautiful day
here in New York I hope everybody had a
wonderful Memorial Day it's good to be
back in the saddle the Rangers won a
huge game in Tampa take that Sarno Game
seven in the garden looking forward to
that little hockey action and I think
I'm a India I think I'm ready for the
show Oh Justin asks I know you're not
big on automation but it's a reality
you're an advisor to HubSpot thoughts on
that space
Justin tremendous question I think this
is a great opportunity for me to clarify
my point of view on automation I don't
love automation to the point where it's
replacing something that I won humble
man's point of view should be done by a
human aka I don't like the notion of an
automatic diem when you follow somebody
and it feels very spammy but I love
automate them we I use automation at
Wine Library like when your order is
confirmed it automatically emails you
and says your order is ready for you I
think that there's a really fine line of
what one would quantify as the thing
that a human should do and the thing
that a computer should do I don't like
when automation automatically populates
somebody's first name into an email and
they're trying to trick and that's what
I feel you know to me the intent of the
automation I you know for example I
asked a lot of people when they sign up
for my YouTube channel to email me that
they did write The Ting you know
direction on that part can't you just
subscribe oh by the way when you do
email me
[Music]
yeah you know that part I tell them to
email me and look I'm getting a lot of
emails and I don't answer everybody one
would argue that the automated response
of like hey thanks for signing up for my
thing and check out the askgaryvee show
and check out pre-order my new book the
askgaryvee book and you know check out
vader that you know one would argue that
there's a lot of you know conversion
there but to me i is a human is gary
vaynerchuk asked you to sign up or for
my newsletter and email me i don't want
when i say email me for that to then be
the computer responds to you right and
so what i do is i when i have a moment i
try to answer a couple of and just say
thank you because that's really was my
whole intent of that and so i think that
i'm a big fan of automation for a lot of
things but but what people are trying to
do is scale humans and there's a human
element that matters in these equations
none of you not a single one of you
watching this video like it when
somebody automates something that is
supposed to act like a human and it's
not so as a company I think automation
is great when you when you apply for
vaynermedia I don't even know if this
happens with the resume getting an
automated response but way too many
people are saying like indi am like hey
thanks for following me and check out my
new ebook like it's not real like that
that to me is the muck and so of course
it's a reality I don't hand deliver
every email there's a lot of things that
are appropriate I argue around
automating the human thing I argue
around outsourcing the human thing I
don't think a celebrity should have
their assistant reply for them as them
if you want to create a team beyonce
account if you want to create you know a
team india account that you know has to
respond because she's become such a
superstar that's fine but not Beyonce
because that wasn't Beyonce doing it I
have this huge argument a long time ago
when everybody got mad at Britney Spears
and I and I argue that Obama wasn't
doing it and everybody got upset and so
everybody's like no he's doing it this
is oh seven Twitter talk it was fun to
see him actually get his own account
recently too
prove that out it matters Scott asks my
computer is sitting in my lap and I'm
reading Twitter on my phone
why exactly Scott this is very easy to
answer my friend why because this has
become the first screen this is the most
important screen in the world no longer
the television and this thing this thing
is dead this is literally like like this
is like an archaic artifact like like
like our kids and friends are gonna be
like well the way they look at like a
like a gameboy or like a Walkman that
are like a VHS tape or like a CD they're
like have you seen a 13 year old look at
a CD by the way I mean it's like what is
this thing the reason this is sitting
here and you're doing that you just
replicate this is because this is the
jam now this is how we communicate not
this and this was the jam versus the
going to my conference room of my office
in my room and sit down on a big thing
now that's archaic the computer that
blew our minds and soon this I wish they
would forgive me to watch whether it's
the watch or the contact lenses or ocula
it's like it's just evolution and so
you're evolving my friend Congrats
Jessica asks if you owned a CrossFit gym
how would you attack the marketplace
Jessica I would attack it in a lot of
ways I think CrossFit is amazingly ripe
for content people hustling people
wearing skimpy clothes people in shape
people competing just a ton of Instagram
a ton of Pinterest a ton of Facebook a
ton of YouTube just content content
content but I would have a very
strategic approach locally if you
actually run a gym I would care
immensely around the 15 mile radius and
so I would also test direct mail I would
test je being with the other one of the
my favorite moves for a local business
is I can't believe so many local
businesses don't do this why not go to
every other local business and say hey
India and use India a lot in this
episode hey India you have a beautiful
flower shop here but you know a lot of
customers neither do I at my CrossFit
gym we need to help each other right
like we need more you need more people
for this what can we do right maybe I
can put your flowers in my gym
and I'll put a sign there and can you do
something for me and that talk that
bizdev with local you know hey Stefan
right like I'm just getting into it now
I'm really now into it let's get this
light away hey Stefan I really like your
sneaker store by the way I'm gonna buy
these sneakers somebody's um you know
but wha you know by the way you know
there's not that many people that come
here Monday through Friday so wouldn't
you make maybe you can put a sneaker
display in my gym and maybe I can have
something here you cool for that he's
cool with that so my friends localized
biz deaths every small business needs
more people
it's the hustle it's the grind you're
competing against the thing called the
Internet and it's gonna win but it's
gonna take 20 30 40 years but every day
it chips away at your pocket every day
the internet comes and it takes another
bill out of every day the internet comes
and it just grabs it just grabs it just
takes your money and so you need to
fight with your other teammates that
have the same problem you have so sure
all the stuff that I've talked about in
102 episodes watch them all there's
plenty of stuff in there to do but good
old-fashioned knocking on doors and biz
Devin with India the flower chop and
stuff on the sneaker shop is very very
important and I'm blown away every time
I go into a local business that they
have all this square footage that
they're not using efficiently cuz there
are the money for inventory for
unlimited sneakers so they just got room
they've got room and in that room maybe
I can put a bench with a weight and
everyone's old what the hell is that but
there's a sign there it says Gary's
CrossFit you know grab this coupon one
month free bizdev locally I'm obsessed
with it but it takes the guts to go
knock on the door and a lot of people
just don't have those guts you like that
oh nice nice
thank you I don't have my money buck
seventy if you were wondering
joke grind Joe on the grind I like it I
wish I was Gary crying I'd kill it maybe
some Vaynerchuk Joe grind asks why is it
a crime to like your own pictures on
Instagram why will you be shunned for it
Joe I'm with you I think here on the
askgaryvee show episode 103 i do not
understand why it's politically
incorrect to like your own picture as a
matter of fact starting here joe going
forward for the next ten pictures as a
social experiment i will be the first
person to like my own photo because
self-esteem is cool kids
it's cool I really think it's okay I
really think it's I don't think it's so
crazy I know that people like think it's
like it's it's funny to see the social
taboos but I'm into it I'm gonna heart
the [ __ ] out of my Instagram photos
going forward Jason asks Gary do you
still believe marketing is heading
towards one-on-one marketing Jason I
still think that the upside the
disproportionate upside is going into
one-on-one marketing I and I know this
because when I do with Twitter video
replies people go crazy and I'm creating
depth I know this because a lot of
people have been following me on
Instagram you should too and and I've
been replying to them in the comments
one of my new hacks this is really you
know Justin who asked the first
questions like give me more tactical
[ __ ] here you go bro here's a good one
here's something I've been really into
right so people follow you right I get
decent amounts of follows most of you
don't you only get one or two or three a
day is it gonna kill you to go into the
last person here's millionaires jr. or
Millions junior private account can't do
it next I know you can't really get in
here d-roc but good here's Austin G
right Austin do you just follow me I've
been hitting his last photo and just
saying thanks for the follow right bro
right and done that level of depth I've
noticed almost 95% this is anecdotal but
9 out of every 10 8 out of every 10
people are freaking
excited because nobody does that and so
here's the thing do I think the
marketing world is going towards
one-on-one aka Thank You economy I think
the thing that I've come to realize is
crap a lot of the stuff that I do I'm an
anomaly because I act like one
I have disproportionate results to the
rest of the world because I'm doing [ __ ]
differently that's why and so do I think
the world's moving in that direction
less because I'm starting to realize I'm
better right and so that's building
inside of me do I think that there's
disproportionate value even more than I
did when I wrote thank you economy you
know why because people only want to
talk more now and listen less and listen
my friends is where the action is
spending a second doing what I just did
the thing that I've been really crushing
on I I think I mean this is where you
guys as a collective really pissed me
off I'm going to show you right now that
replying on Twitter video is incredible
Twitter video response is probably the
best hack right now on Twitter right so
let's here we go here's somebody such a
must-read piece by Gary Vee right by
John T right so I just applied I hit
reply I hit the video I hit the video I
reversed the camera I go that was a
picture that's wrong and I want to do
that camera and then John I really
appreciate him in kind of weird thing
we're actually taping askgaryvee live
right now I'm just saying thanks I
appreciate you now I don't do that
because I'm not usually taping
askgaryvee but I just say hey thanks
where I respond 99% of the video
responses have been liked retweeted
passed on it's that extra second and so
I think the LTV the thing that I live on
el-tee be the thing that I live on LTV
the thing that I live on life time value
you can watch a show once or twice or
you can watch all 103 of them which
become a gateway drug to everything else
that I do for a living you say something
nice about me at a restaurant which
leads to that person digging into
vaynermedia which then makes them a
client of vaynermedia you by 11 copies
of the askgaryvee book that comes out in
February and you give them to ten people
who then discover me because I've put
out a hundred and three of these things
for free
put them behind a paywall for 19 bucks
an episode its LT VLT VLT V and one of
the greatest ways to create LTV when
nobody knows who you are
or you're still small or you're still
grinding you're still climbing the
mountain is being completely and utterly
obsessed with thanking everybody who
gave a [ __ ] enough to follow you on
Instagram because I'm not so sure you
deserve it and I'm not so sure I deserve
it which is why I'm so grateful for when
it happens do you rock give me a mmm can
I get an amen
you like that one right great yeah so
thanks for watching the show and
listening and question of the day are
you gonna take me up on my advice on
replying to people on Instagram and
using Twitter video or are you just
gonna nod your head and give me a again
and just move on and not do the tactics
in a world where people say too much
hyperbole too much inner tranches too
much excuse me too much not in the
trenches too much up in the air
theoretic better DNA I'm giving sound
practical damn advice all the time
you're just not doing it you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them
can you just give me 30 seconds to get
this off my chest once and for all I got
this email yesterday
I want you to look at it again because
you didn't catch it the first time
d-roc help them out and highlight the
part that I'm going to focus on this
time
[Music]
you